في اخبارنا الاخرى ذكرت وكاله الانباء
الكوريه الشماليه ان بيونديانغ اجرت تجربه
على غواصه هجوميه مسيره ذات قدرات نوويه
ردا على المناورات العسكريه التي تقوم بها
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه التجربه
اختبرت نوعا جديدا من الغواصات يطلق عليها
اسم هاي الاثنين بعد اسبوع من الكشف عن
نظام جديد للغواصات المسيره يسمى هايل
واحد مصمم للقيام بهجمات مفاجئه في مياه
العدو وقالت الوكاله ان التجربه اجريت
الاسبوع الماضي وقطعت فيها الغواصه مسافه
الف كيلو متر تحت الماء على مدى واحد
وسبعين ساعه وست دقائق ونجحت في اصابه
نموذج لهدف معاد واضافت ان الاختبار اثبت
تماما اعتماديه نظام الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
تحت الماء وقدرته الهجوميه الفتاكه حسب
تعبيرها